[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene Oggi parliamo di spettacolo
Cos'è lo spettacolo
[Musica]
l'altro giorno vedevo una bella
pubblicità televisiva che rappresentava
delle montagne meravigliose e una voce
fuori campo che diceva che spettacolo
[Musica]
Anche noi abbiamo vissuto spesso questa
possibilità di osservare lo spettacolo
della natura le cascate l'alba
il mare in burrasca
le belle montagne che abbiamo
Anzi c'è la moda adesso di alzarsi di
notte farsi una bella camminata per
andare a vedere l'alba Ah che spettacolo
[Musica]
poi magari prendiamo sonno ci distraiamo
siamo in compagnia del nostro partner ma
l'alba sale comunque
[Musica]
questo potremmo chiamarlo uno spettacolo
naturale
mentre quello di questa sera è un evento
uno spettacolo realizzato dall'uomo
Come può essere un evento artistico
sportivo religioso questi ultimi giorni
abbiamo assistito allo spettacolo della
politica Cosa hanno in comune lo
spettacolo naturale lo spettacolo
realizzato dall'uomo Beh lo dice la
parola lo spettatore lo spettatore è
elemento essenziale
Infatti spettacolo deriva dal latino
spectare
osservare guardare e giudicare lo
spettatore colui che osserva guarda e
che dà un giudizio
si emoziona ride piange si commuove
commenta applaude fischia anche negli
Stati nello spettacolo dello Sport il
pubblico
facori fa delle leola ci sono le trombe
per sostenere la squadra del cuore
è molto importante questo è nel calcio
nello sport l'elemento del tifoso è
fondamentale come anche nei concerti
all'aperto nei concerti rock ci si
scatena per sostenere l'artista
[Musica]
nel calcio sappiamo che tirare un rigore
fuori casa
è estremamente difficile
l'elemento campo è fondamentale
nel calcio possiamo urlare gridare come
nel pallacanestro nel Volley in altri
situazioni il pubblico invece sta
religiosamente in silenzio come nel
tennis e questo aiuta comunque
l'atleta nel suo gioco
[Musica]
Ho naturalmente
Qual è la differenza tra lo spettacolo e
lo sport Beh in teatro la questione
cambia di molto il teatro Da quando c'è
l'eliminazione prima a gas e poi
elettrica si fa il buio si fa il buio e
dunque sembra che ci sia una separazione
tra la platea e palcoscenico tra
spettatore e artista ma non è così
quando si apre il sipario scatta una
relazione
una comunicazione fra platea e
palcoscenico fra artista e attore e
viceversa come il gioco di ping pong Io
lancio voi ricevete nello stesso tempo
Voi lanciate qualcosa a me che ricevo
anche nel buio
[Musica]
il pubblico in maniera spesso
inconsapevole
mentre L'artista è ben consapevole Anzi
prima dell'apertura è sipario il artista
a timore di entrare in scena ha quasi
paura perché non sa chi avrà di fronte
perché ogni sera lo spettatore è diverso
[Musica]
ogni sera lo spettacolo è diverso
quando noi ci siamo abituati con il
lockdown a lavorare di fronte a una
videocamera
questi webinar ci siamo accorti che
tutto sommato Noi partecipiamo qualche
cosa condivisa con altri però se spengo
il microfono posso starnutire senza
disturbare nessuno se tolgo il video
posso mangiare una caramella posso
accettare
posso mettermi le dita nel naso non
cambia nulla
possiamo stare in maglietta in giacca
nelle sedute di laurea online
giacche cravatta
e sotto in mutande e tanto è la stessa
cosa scherzando con gli studenti abbiamo
ragionato che c'era un gran risparmio
sulle scarpe
quando io sono davanti al televisore
vedere un film o sono a vedere l'alba
se io sono distratto si chiude gli occhi
se sto abbracciato la mia compagna il
film continua comunque inesorabilmente
se io sono distratto dall'alba Il sole
sorge comunque non posso fare nulla non
cambia nulla in teatro invece questa
relazione fa sì che ci sia questa
comunicazione questa relazione che va a
emozionare e condizionare chi sta su
questo palco come nello sport il tifoso
è fondamentale Avete presente
le olimpiadi salto in lungo salto lungo
atleta si prepara si concentra e poi si
rivolge al suo pubblico ai tifosi e
comincia a chiedere che cosa
forza forza
e l'atleta
si carica si carica e poi parte con la
sua rincorsa fai il salto record
applausi a fantastico eccezionale
questo salto è il risultato di tanti
fattori la preparazione atletica
[Musica]
Magari anche un po' il favore del vento
perché no ci sta ma soprattutto il
sostegno dato dai tifosi questo salto è
il risultato anche di quanto i tifosi
hanno dato nella carica emotiva e quindi
il risultato di quel salto è anche
merito dei tifosi
o in teatro La cosa è un po' diversa
il teatro devo stare veramente attento a
quello che faccio perché vado a
disturbare le altre persone vado a
comunicare la mia reazione
[Musica]
E allora alcuni consigli
alcuni consigli in teatro anche con il
buio soprattutto con il buio non
chattate la luce disturba il vostro
vicino e arriva e percepito e
palcoscenico
e poi un segno di assenza dello
spettacolo stesso
[Musica]
prima dello spettacolo mangiare poco
altrimenti si rischia di prendere sonno
e se uno prende sonno potrebbe pure
russare questo dà fastidio ai vicini
E vi assicuro si percepisce dal
palcoscenico
[Musica]
se proprio dovete mangiate caramelle con
la carta morbida
perché altrimenti vi assicuro che questo
rumore da tremendamente fastidio al
vicino e si percepisce del palcoscenico
e il teatro lo mettetevi le dita nel
naso perché dal palcoscenico si vede
perfettamente non è un bello spettacolo
Insomma è chiaro che nonostante la
tecnologia abbiamo capito anche dopo il
lockdown che la realtà virtuale non può
sostituire quella reale abbiamo bisogno
della relazione che ci permette di
trasmettere emozioni
[Musica]
vi immaginate l'amore virtuale
Insomma Potrebbe essere causa della fine
del genere umano non è cosa
il rituale non potrà sostituire e quindi
c'è un invito da parte mia
abituiamoci a spegnere ogni tanto i
nostri device i nostri apparati
elettronici e torniamo facciamo questo
sforzo a tornare a comunicare con gli
occhi con i gesti con la parola
[Musica]
e a memorizzare non con lo smartphone
memorizzare con la testa con la mente
con il cuore le emozioni saranno quelle
che vi resteranno indelebili per tutta
la vita perché come ha detto qualcuno
La vita è come un teatro dove ciascuno
di noi è contemporaneamente
attore e spettatore
Grazie
[Applauso]